This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. If you tune it to Saturday Night Live, the weekend after last fall's election, you may remember the sketch. A group of friends, all liberals, are gathered around their TV as states begin to report voter tallies. It doesn't go the way they expect. OK, all she has to do is come back and win Wisconsin, come back in win Michigan, come back in win Pennsylvania.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。如果你在去年大选后的那个周末收看了《周六夜现场》，你可能还记得那个小品。一群朋友，全都是自由派，聚在电视机前，看着各州开始汇报选票统计结果。结果却跟他们预期的不一样。好吧，她现在只需要卷土重来拿下威斯康星州，卷土重来拿下密歇根州，卷土重来拿下宾夕法尼亚州。
And some of the counties are the urban counties. They're so black people vote, lay it. Making jokes about politics, politicians, and voters is a tradition as old as America itself. Cartoonists portrayed King George as a tyrant and a buffoon during the Revolutionary War. More than a century ago, Mark Twain wrote that fleas can be taught nearly anything that a congressman can. And in the 1960s, the Smothers Brothers used their TV platform to criticize the Vietnam War,
其中有些县是城市县。它们的黑人选民很多，靠后。拿政治、政治家和选民开玩笑，是一项和美国历史一样悠久的传统。独立战争期间，漫画家把乔治国王描绘成一个暴君和丑角。一个多世纪前，马克·吐温曾写道，跳蚤几乎可以被训练成和国会议员一样聪明。而在20世纪60年代，斯莫瑟斯兄弟利用他们的电视平台批评越南战争，
much to the chagrin of network sensors. And if you ever get a war with that blood and your boy, I'll be the first to go. But until then, Mr. MacRameira. These days, of course, comedians have a new target, President Donald Trump. Today, we thought we'd talk with one of those comedians, the Iranian-American, Mars Jobrani. For him, the Trump administration ban on travelers
这让电视网的审查人员感到非常恼火。如果你真遇到那种流血的战争，把你的孩子送上战场，我肯定是第一个去的。但在此之前，麦克雷拉先生。当然，如今喜剧演员们有了一个新目标，唐纳德·特朗普总统。今天，我们想和其中一位喜剧演员聊聊，他就是伊朗裔美国人马兹·乔布拉尼。对马兹来说，特朗普政府对来自包括伊朗在内的
from seven nations, including Iran, has hit close to home. Mars is a liberal and has strong feelings about President Trump, feelings that are increasingly showing up in a stand-up routine. Listen, first of all, whether you like Trump or not, you got to admit, when he first started running, everybody thought it was a joke. Everybody was like, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, He was just a kid. His family fled Iran during the 1979 revolution. Over the years, Mars has made a name for himself with comedy that draws on parenting, Persian culture, and politics.
七个国家的旅客实施的禁令，让他感到切肤之痛。马兹是一个自由派，对特朗普总统有着强烈的感情，这种感情越来越多地出现在他的单口喜剧表演中。听着，首先，不管你喜不喜欢特朗普，你都得承认，他刚开始参选时，每个人都觉得是个笑话。每个人都觉得，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，他当时只是个孩子。他的家人在1979年革命期间逃离了伊朗。多年来，马兹凭借取材于育儿、波斯文化和政治的喜剧赢得了名声。
He's the author of, I'm not a terrorist, but I've played one on TV. He also has a new show out on CBS. It's called Superior Donuts. Mars, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. Mars, you know, I've always had the sense that comedians are really social scientists, because you can't do comedy unless you have a really sharp eye for human nature. There's a joke that you did some months ago that reinforced this idea for me.
他是《我不是恐怖分子，但我曾在电视里演过一个》的作者。他在CBS还有一档新节目，叫做《九五至尊甜甜圈》。马兹，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。谢谢邀请我来。马兹，你知道的，我一直觉得喜剧演员其实就是社会学家，因为如果你对人性没有敏锐的洞察力，你就做不好喜剧。几个月前你讲过的一个笑话就强化了我这种想法。
It's about Donald Trump's attitude toward immigrants. Listen, the number one thing I've heard Trump supporters say, number one thing, I love him because he says what's on his mind. He just he says was on his mind. He just says was on his mind. He just says was on his mind. You go, what are your thoughts on his policies? I don't know about his policies. He just says was on his mind. I thought that was the dumbest thing I'd ever heard.
那是关于唐纳德·特朗普对移民的态度的。听着，我听到特朗普支持者说得最多的一点，最重要的一点就是，我爱他，因为他心里想什么就说什么。他就是心里想什么就说什么。他就是心里想什么就说什么。他就是心里想什么就说什么。你去问，你对他的政策有什么看法？我不知道他的政策是什么。他就是心里想什么就说什么。我觉得这是我听过最蠢的话。
So I went to visit my mother, my own mother, Iranian lady. She had fallen for the line. My mom goes, ma' Ma, I like this guy, because he's saved what is on his mind. I go, Ma, are you crazy? He's anti-immigrant. If he became president, your relatives couldn't come to visit you.
于是我去看望我的母亲，我亲爱的母亲，一位伊朗女士。她也信了这一套。我妈说，妈，我喜欢这家伙，因为他心里想什么就说什么。我说，妈，你疯了吗？他是反移民的。如果他当了总统，你的亲戚就不能来看你了。
She goes, I don't like them anyway. So, Ma, you predicted what the Trump administration was going to do where travelers from Iran months before it was announced. Can you tell me what's next in Donald Trump's playbook? You know how hard it's been to write material because to do stand-up comedy, it takes time for the material to develop. So you'll come up with a joke, you'll tweak it, you'll work it for six months, you'll really fine tune it, and now you've got a good bit. Well, with Trump every day, there's something you come again, and then sometimes you do a
她说，反正我也不喜欢他们。所以，马兹，你在特朗普政府宣布禁止来自伊朗的旅客前几个月，就已经预言了他们会这么做。你能告诉我唐纳德·特朗普的下一个剧本是什么吗？你知道写素材有多难吗，因为要做单口喜剧，素材的发展需要时间。所以你会想出一个笑话，然后调整它，打磨六个月，真正精雕细琢一番，然后你才算有了一个好段子。好吧，有了特朗普，每天都有新情况，然后有时候你讲一个
joke that already feels dated. I did a joke last night about the travel ban, and it just, it felt dated to me already, although you can continue to do it. So nobody knows what he's going to do next. And I keep saying that Trump is good for comedy, but bad for the world. What was the joke about the travel ban? Well, it's just that I've been doing jokes about, I talk about how when the protests happened
听起来已经过时的笑话。我昨晚讲了一个关于旅行禁令的笑话，它给我的感觉已经过时了，尽管你还可以继续讲。所以没人知道他接下来会做什么。我一直在说，特朗普对喜剧有好处，但对世界没好处。那个关于旅行禁令的笑话是什么？嗯，就是我一直在讲一些笑话，我谈到当机场爆发针对旅行禁令的抗议时，我去了现场，我其实去了洛杉矶国际机场（LAX）参加了抗议。
for the travel ban at the airport, I went down, I actually went down at the LAX and I protested. And one of the observations I said I made was that I realized quickly that white people born in America protest differently than people of color or anyone who is an immigrant. Because I'm an immigrant. And this actually happened. We were all protesting. But then when the cops came out and riot gear, I kind of felt like I wanted to go protest on the side,
我观察到的其中一点是，我很快意识到，在美国出生的白人抗议的方式，和有色人种或任何移民都不一样。因为我是移民。而这确实发生了。我们都在抗议。但后来当警察穿着防暴装备出来时，我有点想去旁边抗议，
whereas all the white people just kept going at the cop. And I'm going, I was like, are you crazy? But they were, one guy, this actually happened, one guy had his finger in the face of the cop in riot gear. The cop had his baton, he was ready to go. This white guy had his finger in the face of the cop and just, I don't know, what are you saying, but it looked like he was saying something along the lines of, this is my right and
而所有的白人都还在继续跟警察理论。而我在想，我在想，你们疯了吗？但他们确实有一个人——这真的发生了——一个人把手指戳到了那个穿着防暴装备的警察脸。警察拿着警棍，随时准备动手。这个白人把手指戳到警察脸上，然后，我不知道，你在说什么，但看起来他说的差不多是，这是我的权利，
I'm going to protest or whatever. And I got nervous for him. And I got nervous for us. I got nervous for everybody. I can tell that you feel very strongly about Donald Trump and that there's much about this administration that upsets you. But I'm also wondering what effect this has on your comedy. I mean, it's hard to be funny when you're angry at the same time, isn't it?
我要抗议之类的话。我替他捏了一把汗。我也替我们捏了一把汗。我替所有人都捏了一把汗。我看得出你对唐纳德·特朗普有着强烈的感情，这个政府有很多事情让你感到心烦意乱。但我也想知道，这会对你的喜剧产生什么影响。我是说，当你同时在生气的时候，要做到搞笑很难，不是吗？
Yeah, well, I mean, some people have made a living doing that. Lewis Black was one of my favorite comedians, his angry, and he's funny, very funny. That's the last person on f***ing earth. You want to give a firearm to. Somebody teach you in the fifth grade are you me you don't think at some point she's gonna reach in there does she go so there are those who have that personality my personality is probably not as angry on stage so what I do is if I do get into a topic like that I just
是的，好吧，我是说，有些人靠这个谋生。路易斯·布莱克是我最喜欢的喜剧演员之一，他很愤怒，但他很搞笑，非常搞笑。那是他妈的地球上最后一个人。你想给枪支的人。五年级教你的，是你还是我，你难道不认为在某个时候她会把手伸进去然后去吗？所以确实有那种性格的人。我的性格在舞台上可能没那么愤怒，所以我要做的是，如果我谈到这样一个话题，我就会
make sure there's a punchline coming afterwards so I think you just got to keep in mind to have punchlines in there I do have people, you know, I've been very active now social media and I have people comment and say stick to comedy Your comedian stick to comedy and my response to those people is Then you should stick to accounting. Don't don't criticize my comedy. I mean, it's like we are you are what you are I am a political human being. I have, that's one of my interests. I studied political science in college. I was actually gonna get my PhD in polyps high.
确保后面会有一个俏皮话（punchline），所以我认为你只需要记住里面要有俏皮话。我确实有些人，你知道的，我现在在社交媒体上非常活跃，有些人会评论说，专注于喜剧吧，你是个喜剧演员，专注于喜剧吧。我对这些人的回应是：那你们应该去专注于会计。不要，不要批评我的喜剧。我的意思是，这就好比我们是，你就是你，我是一个有政治意识的人。我有，这是我的兴趣之一。我在大学里学的是政治学。我其实打算去拿政治学的博士学位。
And a lot of my material from early on in my career dealt with politics. So I've always considered myself as somebody who enjoys political humor. So I'm not gonna stop. I know you spent time watching Fox News and the Age of Donald Trump. And in some of your comedy,
而且我职业生涯早期的很多素材都涉及政治。所以我一直认为自己是一个喜欢政治幽默的人。所以我不会停下来。我知道你花时间看了福克斯新闻和唐纳德·特朗普时代。在你的某些喜剧中，
you talk about how this changes your own perception. It's based on fear. It's all based, like, I watch it from time to time to see what the other side is thinking a little bit. You know what I'm saying? I wanna like, like, and then once you watch it a little bit, you start like doubting the people around you. I'm like, maybe my cousin Mahmoud is up to some...
你谈到了这如何改变了你自己的看法。这是基于恐惧。这一切都基于，就像我时不时看它一眼，想看看另一方在想什么。你知道我在说什么吗？我想像，就像，一旦你看了一点，你就会开始怀疑你身边的人。我想，也许我的表弟马哈茂德在搞什么……
F***ing. F***ing. You're saying that you start to buy it? You know, it's very similar to what happened at the Republican National Convention. I mean, when they kept saying make America great again and got to make America safe and America's in danger, and it's this, if you buy into that fear, I mean, they really were scaring people at that Republican National Convention to the point where you thought, oh, if I'm there, I'm thinking I shouldn't go out in the streets because Muslims are coming to get me. And I think that if you watch those enough that you slowly start doubting and start when
他妈的。他妈的。你是说你开始相信了？你知道的，这和共和党全国代表大会上发生的事情非常相似。我是说，当他们不停地说让美国再次伟大，必须让美国安全，美国处于危险之中，就是这样，如果你接受了这种恐惧，我是说，他们在那个共和党全国代表大会上真的把人们吓坏了，以至于你会想，哦，如果我在那儿，我会觉得我不应该走上街头，因为穆斯林要来抓我了。而且我认为如果你看这些看够了，你就会慢慢开始怀疑，并且开始当
you go into a subway store and there's a Muslim guy behind the counter, you start doubting and start when you go into a subway store and there's a Muslim guy behind the counter, you start doubting his intentions a little bit. How do you take that and turn that into comedy? How do you take stuff that's very serious that people potentially care about, that people are potentially hurt by? How do you take that and turn that into a joke or a punchline? Is there a method to doing it? I think sincere emotions and feelings about a subject, your sincere experiences with a subject. I talk about, for example, talking about the fear of ISIS.
你走进一家赛百味（Subway）店，柜台后面有一个穆斯林伙计，你开始怀疑，开始怀疑他的意图。你怎么把这些转化为喜剧？你怎么把那些非常严肃、人们可能很在乎、人们可能因此受到伤害的事情拿来，把它变成一个笑话或俏皮话？这里面有什么方法吗？我认为是对一个主题真诚的情感和感受，你对一个主题真诚的经历。比如我谈到，谈到对ISIS的恐惧。
I was doing a little bit about how I actually went to Turkey in November to do a show. And at 7 a.m. one morning, somebody rang my door at the hotel room. And I was jet lagged and I got up and I went and looked through the little people and I look out and there was three Arab guys standing there in a triangular fashion, like one standing in the center, two flanking him, and I honestly, for a second, I thought, oh my God, ISIS has come to get me. And I just was scared, and I go, who is it? And then the poor Arab guy, he kind of looked around and he goes, Mustafa, and I go, no, there's no Mustafa.
我当时正在讲一个小段子，讲我去年11月去土耳其演出。有一天早上7点，有人按了我酒店房间的门铃。我有严重的时差，我爬起来，透过猫眼往外看，外面站着三个阿拉伯小伙子，呈三角形站立，一个站在中间，两个在他两侧老实说，有一秒钟，我的天呐，ISIS来抓我了。我当时吓坏了，我说，是谁呀？然后那个可怜的阿拉伯小伙子环顾了一下四周，说道：“穆斯塔法？”我说：“不，这里没有穆斯塔法。”
He goes, oh, sorry, I thought Mustafa. So there's no Mustafa. He goes, oh, sorry. I thought Mustafa. So they had come to the wrong door. Just three Arab guys, I guess their buddy Mustafa must have been, you know, two doors that I don't know. But that's where, again, it became, when I was talking about on stage, it was getting laughs because it was making fun of myself and how I had fallen for this fear. So I think you take those situations and you talk about the odds of you actually having something this happened to your low but how you can buy into it and how I bought into it. One of the things I find very interesting about your comedy from a psychological perspective
他说：“哦，抱歉，我以为是穆斯塔法。”所以没有穆斯塔法。他说，哦，抱歉。我以为是穆斯塔法。所以他们敲错了门。只是三个阿拉伯小伙子，我猜他们的好兄弟穆斯塔法一定在，你知道的，隔了两扇门，我不知道。但这就是，再次，当我在舞台上谈论这件事时，它博得了笑声，因为它是在取笑我自己，取笑我是如何陷入这种恐惧的。所以我觉得你拿这些情况来谈论你真正遇到这种事的几率其实很低，但你是如何相信它的，以及我是如何相信它的。从心理学的角度来看，我觉得你的喜剧中非常有趣的一件事是，
Mars is you talk about how being surrounded by stereotypes and profiling changes the way you think about yourself. You did an interview some time ago with the public radio show The World and I want to play a short extra from it. So this feeling I used to have after September 11th, I felt like whenever you passed through the metal detector, you just felt guilty. And I would go through it and I would hear like, I knew it. So that's a joke, of course. But I understand this feeling of being suspicious of even yourself might have some parallels
马兹，你谈到被刻板印象和种族 profiling（Profiling指执法人员基于对特定种族、肤色、宗教信仰或国籍的刻板印象进行嫌疑人甄别和盘查）包围是如何改变你对自己的看法的。不久前你接受了公共广播节目《世界》的采访，我想播放其中的一小段。所以这种感觉我以前在911之后经常有，我觉得每当你通过金属探测器时，你就会觉得有罪。我走过去，听到类似“我早就知道”的声音。这当然是个笑话。但我理解这种甚至对自己产生怀疑的感觉可能有一些相似之处，
in real life as you've gone around the country to perform live shows. Yeah, absolutely. I mean, listen, we get bombarded with this stuff every day, every day, every day. So it's going to be in our minds. It's going to be there. I mean, I did another bit in my special called, I'm not a terrorist, but I've played one on TV. I do a joke about how I say, I realized that I racially profiling this, this actually happened again where I was on an airplane sitting towards the front. And before the door closed, this blonde,
正如你在全国各地进行现场表演时所经历的那样。是的，绝对的。我是说，听着，我们每天、每天、每天都被这些东西狂轰滥炸。所以它肯定会留在我们的脑海里。它肯定会在那里。我是说，我在我的专场中做了另一个段子，叫做《我不是恐怖分子，但我曾在电视里演过一个》。我讲了一个笑话，我说，我意识到我是在对这个进行种族 profiling，这又发生了，当时我在一架飞机上，坐在靠前的位置。在机舱门关闭之前，这个金发碧眼的
girl, American girl, probably in her mid20s. She came running to the front, seemed like she was having a panic attack and just was saying, I got to get off this plane, I can't do this, I can't fly and the stewardess came up and goes, what's going on, we're about to leave. And no, I can't, I got to get off. And then the stewardess said, okay, let me ask the pilot, the pilot came out and said, okay, fine, you can get off. So she just walked off. And then we closed the door and we took off. And as we were taxing, the passenger next to me looked at me and said, okay fine, you can get off. So she just walked off. And then we closed the door and we took off. And as we were taxing, the passenger looked next to me, looked at me and said, shouldn't we check to see if she had any luggage underneath? And my thought to the passenger was, no, she was just some 20-year-old white girl. And baggage that she had was in her head. Whereas the honest truth is, again, this is how we all profile because of what
女孩，美国女孩，大概二十岁出头。她一路小跑着冲到前面，看起来像是在惊恐发作，嘴里一直说，我得下飞机，我受不了了，我没办法飞行。空姐走过来问，怎么了，我们马上就要起飞了。不，我不能，我得下去。然后空姐说，好吧，我去问问机长。机长出来说，好吧，行，你可以下去。于是她就走下去了。然后我们关上门，起飞了。当我们在滑行时，坐在我旁边的一名乘客看着我，说，好吧，行，你可以下去。所以她就走下去了。然后我们关上门，起飞了。当我们在滑行时，坐在我旁边的乘客看着我，说，难道我们不应该检查一下她在下面有没有行李吗？我对那名乘客的想法是，不，她只是个二十岁的白人女孩。她所有的行李都在她的脑子里。而老实说，再次说明，这就是我们所有人因为所见所闻而产生刻板印象的方式。
we've seen. And I do this when I would do this in the, when I did this in my standup, I picked somebody out in the audience. There was an Egyptian. And I said, I guarantee you, I said, next time an airplane is about to take off, go sit in the back of the plane you're in and just come running to the front. And with your thickest arabic accent just say i have to get off this plane right now i cannot do this i have to get off this plane and see if they let you off the plane they they will definitely stop the
当我这样做的时候，当我在我的单口喜剧中这样做时，我在观众中挑了一个人。那是一个埃及人。我说，我向你保证，我说，下次有飞机快要起飞时，你去坐在飞机的最后面，然后一路小跑冲到前面。用你最浓重的阿拉伯口音说，我现在必须下飞机，我受不了了，我必须下飞机，看看他们放不放你下飞机。他们绝对会拦下
plane they will search the plane they were they were you know president trump will give a speech that they that they thwarted a terrorist attack so what's that based on that's based on these stereotypes that we've seen so many times over and over again. And so, yeah, I think we all stereotype. And that's not a good thing. When we come back, I'm going to ask Maaz about the psychology of crafting a joke,
飞机，他们会搜查飞机，他们会，你知道的，特朗普总统会发表一个演讲，宣称他们挫败了一起恐怖袭击。所以这说明了什么？这说明了我们无数次看到的这些刻板印象。所以，是的，我认为我们都有刻板印象。这不是一件好事。稍后回来，我将问问马兹关于构思一个笑话的心理学，
and whether comedy can actually change our attitudes to what people from other cultures. Stay with us. Más, you've performed comedy all over the world in the United States, the Middle East. Are there jokes that work here that don't work for example in Saudi Arabia? Yeah, I mean that's for the most part a lot of material works, especially if you're doing material about your family, everywhere you go, when you do kid material parents seem to sympathize. And I think we can all agree that kids can be the common enemy sometimes. But there are jokes that sometimes don't work as well. I used to do joke where I said, I said having young kids, your time is not your own time.
以及喜剧是否真的能改变我们对来自其他文化的人的看法。请继续收听。马兹，你在世界各地都表演过喜剧，在美国、中东。有些笑话在这里管用，但在沙特阿拉伯却不管用，对吗？是的，我的意思是，在大多数情况下，很多素材都管用，特别是如果你在讲关于你的家庭的素材时，无论你走到哪里，当你讲育儿素材时，父母们似乎都能感同身受。我想我们都会同意，有时孩子可以成为共同的敌人。但有些笑话有时效果没那么好。我以前讲过一个笑话，我说，我曾说过，有了年幼的孩子，你的时间就不再属于你了。
You have to take care of your to-do list while they're napping. You're almost like a Navy SEAL. You gotta be ready to go any time, any place. I used to do joke where I said, the other day the kids were napping and I went to my wife, I said, hey, the kids are napping.
你必须在他们打盹的时候去完成你的待办事项清单。你简直就像海豹突击队（Navy SEAL）。你必须随时随地准备出发。我以前讲过一个笑话，我说，有一天孩子们在打盹，我走到我妻子身边，我说，嘿，孩子们在打盹。
You know, let's make love. And my wife said, I'm not in the mood. I said, well, I'm not in the mood either. But the kids are sleeping, you know let's let's make love and my wife said I'm not in the mood I said well I'm not in the mood either but the kids are sleeping let's go move it move it you know it's we got to kill bin Laden let's do this and then jokingly I turn to the audience I said that's what we call sex in my house killing bin Laden and then I and and so that was the joke and in America people appreciated it. But then I was doing a show in Saudi Arabia. And as you may know, the Bin Laden family is a respected family in Saudi Arabia.
你知道的，我们做爱吧。我妻子说，我没心情。我说，好吧，我也没有心情。但孩子们在睡觉，你知道的，我们做爱吧，我妻子说，我没心情，我说，好吧，我也没有心情，但孩子们在睡觉，我们动起来，动起来，你知道的，我们得干掉本·拉登，我们干吧。然后我开玩笑地转向观众，我说，那就是我们在家里所说的“干掉本·拉登”。然后我，所以这就是那个笑话，在美国人们很欣赏它。但后来我在沙特阿拉伯做了一场演出。正如你可能知道的那样，本·拉登家族在沙特阿拉伯是一个受人尊敬的家族。
So I wasn't sure how they're gonna respond. And so I tried the joke and it kind of got a lukewarm response. Like a nervous response. Like a nervous response. Like a nervous response. Like some people in the audience, like the younger guys in the audience were laughing, but the older, you know, families were not, because I think they just felt it was disrespectful.
所以我不知道他们会有什么反应。所以我尝试了这个笑话，结果反响平平。就像一种紧张的反应。就像一种紧张的反应。就像一种紧张的反应。就像观众中的一些人，比如观众中年轻的小伙子们在笑，但年长的，你知道的，家庭没有笑，因为我觉得他们只是觉得这很不尊重人。
So yeah, there's been times when some jokes don't go over as well, but, you know, live and learn. So over the years, your comedy has often addressed Persian culture and tried to demystify that culture for other Americans. This is a clip from your comedy special. I'm not a terrorist, but I've played one on TV. Persians, the Persians were very formal. We're a very formal culture.
所以，是的，有时候有些笑话效果没那么好，但是，你知道，吃一堑长一智。所以多年来，你的喜剧经常涉及波斯文化，并试图为其他美国人揭开这种文化的神秘面纱。这是你的喜剧专场中的一个片段。《我不是恐怖分子，但我曾在电视里演过一个》。波斯人，波斯人非常正式。我们是一种非常正式的文化。
I'll tell you how I realize how formal we are, okay? This happened recently. I was at a Persian event and I was walking and there was this Persian lady saying that I stepped on her toe accidentally, I said, I'm sorry and she goes, no, please, my foot is too long. You know, you know, you know, you know, you know, you know, you know, you know, you know, you know,
我来告诉你我是怎么意识到我们有多正式的，好吗？这事不久前刚发生过。我在参加一个波斯人的活动，我正走着，然后这位波斯女士说我踩到了她的脚趾，不小心踩到的，我说，我很抱歉。她说，不，请原谅，我的脚太长了。你知道的，你知道的，你知道的，你知道的，你知道的，你知道的，你知道的，你知道的，你知道的，你知道的，
she took the blame. That please, I should never have been here in the first place. Where did the idea for that joke come from? This actually happened. I was at an event, this Iranian fundraiser, and I stepped on this lady's toes. I didn't write the joke. I just literally stepped on her toes, and I said, I'm sorry, and she literally said,
她把责任揽到了自己身上。拜托，我本来就不该来这里。那个笑话的灵感是从哪里来的？这确实发生了。我当时在一个活动上，这是一个伊朗人的募捐活动，我踩了一个女士的脚趾。我没有写这个笑话。我真的只是踩了她的脚趾，我说，我很抱歉，她真的说，
no, please, don't worry, it was my fault, my foot was too long. She said that, and that same night I went on stage, it just it just wrote itself and I just basically reported what happened and it was funny because she stood up from the back and she goes that was me and I go yeah and I said I told you guys I said I'm not making this up. I understand that one of the battles you fought over the years is to get roles in television and in movies that allow villains including including terrorists, to be played with psychological depth. How's that worked out? Well, that was an early battle, I would say.
不，请别担心，是我的错，我的脚太长了。她说了这话，当天晚上我就上台了，这个笑话简直是自己写出来的，我基本上就是把发生的事情复述了一遍，而且很好笑，因为她从后面站起来说，那个人就是我。我说，对，我对你们说过，我没有胡编乱造。我明白，多年来你一直在争取的一场战斗是，在电视和电影中获得一些角色，让反派——
That was early on in my career. I've been doing this now 18 years. So around the year 2000, I was, I still had a day job, I had a desk job, I was an assistant in an advertising agency. So I was looking for some TV gigs that would help me or film gigs that would help me be able to financially subsist without the day job. So I was ready to take anything. Then I got, I auditioned for and was cast in a Chuck Norris movie of the week called The
包括恐怖分子——能够展现出心理深度。进展得怎么样？嗯，那是一场早期的战斗，可以说。那是我的职业生涯早期。我干这个已经18年了。所以在2000年左右，我，我当时还有一份正职，我有一份文职工作，是一家广告公司的助理。所以我一直在寻找一些电视工作或电影工作，能帮我在经济上维持生计，不用再做那份白天的正职。所以我什么都愿意接。然后我接到了查克·诺里斯（Chuck Norris）的一部电视电影的试镜并被选中，片名叫《总统的人：沙漠雄狮》。
President's Man Align in the Sand. America has come under siege. Mr. President, with our worst fears have been realized. But terror is just... And in this movie, I was to play an Afghan terrorist who was going to blow up a building in Chicago. And this was before September 11th that happened. So, as you just said, I decided to take the part, thinking to myself that perhaps through my acting ability,
美国已经遭到围攻。总统先生，我们最可怕的恐惧已经变成现实。但恐怖只是……在这部电影里，我将扮演一个阿富汗恐怖分子，他要在芝加哥炸毁一栋大楼。这是911事件发生之前。所以，正如你刚才所说，我决定接下这个角色，心里想着，也许通过我的演技，
I could show why this guy was so upset about America and to the point where he wanted to blow up a building. I really kind of basically misled myself thinking that maybe my acting will show why this guy was doing what he was doing. But when I went down to Dallas where they were filming this and went to the wardrobe fitting and they said, here's your shirt, here's your pants, and here's your turban. And then I told the wardrobe lady, I said, oh no, no, I said, actually Afghans in America don't wear turban. I really want to get this
我可以展现为什么这家伙对美国如此不满，以至于他想要炸毁一栋大楼。我真的是在某种程度上误导了自己，以为也许我的演技会展现出这家伙为什么要这么做。但当我来到达拉斯他们拍摄的地方试装时，他们说，这是你的衬衫，这是你的裤子，这是你的头巾（turban）。然后我告诉服装大姐，我说，哦，不，不，我说，其实在美国的阿富汗人不戴头巾。我真的很想把这个
right. You know, it's Indian Sikhs who wear turban. So let's get this right. And she said, listen, the producers want you to wear a turban. I said, listen, you let them know. I've done my research. Afghans in America do not wear turbans. And then the next day, I came back to put on my clothes and there was my shirt, my pants, and what looked like a scarf. So I thought that she talked to them and they'd agreed. And I said, well, thank you for talking to them them and I'm happy that everyone's agreed that I she's like I don't mind being the scarf wearing terrorists
弄对。你知道的，是印度锡克教徒才戴头巾。所以我们得弄对。她说，听着，制片人希望你戴头巾。我说，听着，你告诉他们。我做过调查了。在美国的阿富汗人不戴头巾。然后第二天，我回去穿衣服，那里放着我的衬衫、裤子，还有一个看起来像围巾的东西。所以我以为她跟他们谈过了，他们同意了。我说，嗯，谢谢你跟他们谈，我很高兴大家都同意我……她好像说，我不介意当一个戴围巾的恐怖分子。
And she goes that's not a scarf. That's the turbine. You just got to wrap it back up And I go oh come on so I wore the turbine. I feel like an idiot and so I came back to Los Angeles and I told my agents. I don't want to do any more terrorist parts. And so, and that was only the second terrorist part I'd ever done. And then, and then the TV show 24 called, and they said, we have a terrorist, and I said, no thank you. And they said, but he changes his mind halfway through the mission. And I said, ooh, the ambivalent terrorist. Well, that's interesting.
她说，那不是围巾。那是头巾。你只需要把它重新缠上就行了。我说，哦，拜托。所以我戴上了头巾。觉得自己像个白痴，然后我回到洛杉矶，告诉我的经纪人：我再也不想演恐怖分子了。所以，那是我演过的仅有的第二个恐怖分子角色。然后，然后电视剧《24小时》打来电话，他们说，我们有个恐怖分子角色，我说，不，谢谢。他们说，但他在任务进行到一半时改变了主意。我说，哦，这个犹豫不决的恐怖分子。嗯，这很有意思。
So I played that terrorist, and that was the last time I played a terrorist, and I haven't played one since. Some time ago, Ma'am, I came by a bit that you did that reminded me of a recent episode of Hidden Brain that looked at the subject of immigration. I swear to God, I was in an Uber with an older Armenian guy, this guy Love Trump. Barely spoke English, but he loved Trump. He was trying to tell me what a great politician he is. He kept saying what a great politician he is. The whole drive, this guy, Donald Trump,
所以我演了那个恐怖分子，那是我最后一次演恐怖分子，从那以后再也没演过。不久前，马兹，我偶然看到你的一段演出，让我想到了《Hidden Brain》最近一期关于移民主题的节目。我向上帝发誓，我当时坐着一个老亚美尼亚人的Uber，这家伙热爱特朗普。英语勉强说得通，但他热爱特朗普。他试图告诉我特朗普是个多么伟大的政治家。他不停地说特朗普是个多么伟大的政治家。一路上，这个家伙，唐纳德·特朗普，
number one politician, very good politician, number one politician, very good number one politician, very good number one, very good number one, very good number one, very good, Father, I got dude, he's anti-immigrant. You're an immigrant. He goes, yes, but I'm here. LAUGHTER
第一政治家，非常好的政治家，第一政治家，非常好，第一政治家，非常好，第一，非常好，第一，非常好，第一，非常好。老兄，他是反移民的。你是个移民。他说，是的，但我已经在这儿了。笑声
We recently talked with Cuban-American American researcher Maria Cristina Garcia. And she told me that this has been a repeated feature of US immigration. Very soon after people get here, they want to slam the door on those who come after them. So there's some historical insight in that joke. Yeah, I've been experiencing it. I experienced it during the campaign and that Armenian guy was a real guy and he really loved Trump and it made in and opened my eyes and then I heard it more and more in my shows. I was actually
我们最近采访了古巴裔美国研究员玛丽亚·克里斯蒂娜·加西亚（Maria Cristina Garcia）。她告诉我，这是美国移民史上的一个重复出现的现象。人们来到这里后不久，就会想要对后来者关上大门。所以那个笑话里有一些历史洞察。是的，我一直在经历它。我在竞选期间经历过，那个亚美尼亚人是个真人，他真的很喜欢特朗普，这让我大开眼界，后来在我的演出中我越来越多地听到这种声音。我当时其实
doing a show in Houston where there was a mixed crowd of different backgrounds and there was a white couple who they seemed Republican-y, just the way they were interacting with me when I was talking to them. And I thought there were going to be the ones that were going to yell back at me when I did my Trump jokes. But they didn't. Instead, this Lebanese guy, when I said, when I did the bit and I say to my mom, hey, mom, he's anti-immigrant, Trump is anti-immigrant.
在休斯顿演出，那里有一群不同背景的混合观众，有一对白人夫妇，他们看起来很像共和党支持者，从他们跟我互动的方式来看，当我跟他们说话的时候。我以为当我讲特朗普的笑话时，他们会是对我大喊大叫的人。但他们没有。相反，这个黎巴嫩伙计，当我说，当我讲那个段子，我对妈妈说，嘿，妈妈，他是反移民的，特朗普是反移民的。
The Lebanese guy in the audience goes, he's anti-illegal immigrant. It's amazing how they want to distinguish themselves, but I feel bad because I go, where's your empathy? So with that question of empathy in mind, do you think comedy can actually change anything? Does it change the way that people think? Yeah, I think comedy is a good way to help people change their minds. I think that if you're laughing and getting a message across, it's a lot easier than when somebody is screaming in your face.
观众席里的那个黎巴嫩伙计喊道：“他是反对非法移民！”令人惊奇的是他们如何想要划清界限，但我感到难过，因为我在想，你们的同理心在哪里？带着对同理心的质疑，你认为喜剧真的能改变什么吗？它能改变人们的思维方式吗？是的，我认为喜剧是帮助人们改变想法的好方法。我认为如果你在笑的同时传达了一个信息，这比有人在你脸大喊大叫要容易得多。
So I've had people, you know, I know, for example, after September 11th, when I was part of the Accessive Evil Comedy Tour and it premiered on Comedy Central in 2007, we got emails from people, a few of them saying one guy in particular, I remember saying that he said he goes after September 11th, he said, I really hated Arabs and Muslims and people from the Middle East, but he goes having senior guys as special, it made me realize that there's good people from there as well. And part of that also is not just the jokes that we're doing and being comedians on stage, but also if you look out in our audience
所以我遇到过这样的人，你知道，我知道，例如，在911之后，当我参加“邪恶轴心喜剧巡回演出”（Axis of Evil Comedy Tour），并于2007年在喜剧中心（Comedy Central）首播时，我们收到了人们的电子邮件，其中一些人——其中有一个人我特别记得——他说，在911之后，他说，我真的很讨厌阿拉伯人、穆斯林和中东人，但他说，看了你们这些家伙的专场，让我意识到那里也有好人。而这其中一部分原因不仅是我们做的笑话和作为舞台上的喜剧演员，而且如果你看看我们的观众
and you see people from those backgrounds, just laughing, I think it makes people realize that there's good people from everywhere. So yeah, I do think that comedy can help change people's minds. Master Brownie, thank you so much for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Thanks for having me. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Tara Boyle. Our staff includes Maggie Penman, Jenny Schmidt, René Clarre, Raina Cohen, and Chloe Conley.
看到来自那些背景的人也在欢笑，我认为这让人们意识到哪里都有好人。所以，是的，我确实认为喜剧可以帮助改变人们的想法。马兹·乔布拉尼，非常感谢你今天来到《Hidden Brain》。谢谢邀请我。本期《Hidden Brain》由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）制作。我们的工作人员包括玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）、珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、勒内·克拉尔（René Klahr）、雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）和克洛伊·康利（Chloe Conley）。
Our unsung hero this week is Stephen Hapton's star. Steve's a data scientist at NPR and helps us understand how audiences are listening to shows like Hidden Brain. He loves numbers and loves bringing numbers to life. Steve's also a walking reminder of the value of that old saw when you want something done, always ask the busiest person. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. And then she comes back but ma's, when have Americans ever thought of Iranians as terrorists ever? Never.
我们本周的无名英雄是斯蒂芬·哈普顿斯塔（Stephen Haptonstahl）。史蒂夫是NPR的数据科学家，他帮助我们了解听众是如何收听像《Hidden Brain》这样的节目的。他热爱数字，也热爱让数字变得生动。史蒂夫也是一个活生生的提醒，提醒我们那句老话的价值：如果你想把事情做好，总是去问最忙的人。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。然后她回来了，但是马兹，美国人什么时候把伊朗人当成过恐怖分子？从来没有。
It was like apparently you weren't here during the hostage crisis! I was getting my crisis! I was getting my f***ing t***. Where were you? There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就像——显然你当时不在人质危机期间！我当时正在遭遇我的危机！我当时正在遭遇我他妈的危机。你当时在哪儿？本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。